I decided to travel from Sydney to the
Australian bush a dangerous land where
only the strong survive that's why I
hired someone strong to guide me Kevin
good to see you it's good to see you
this is a best that I wore in the 80s in
New York on the club scene yeah what do
you think of my arms just before we go
any further muscles you could do a bit
more work this is a southern tree
funnel-web not just in trees they live
also under rocks this thing can kill me
absolutely yes within 20 minutes these
are under rocks and what's the way we've
just done the ropes so I'm just
gesturing around like they're everywhere
why are we here why did we come here
because we just meet if the four seasons
hotel lobby you could have had iced teas
and we couldn't you should have show me
the same book this thing is under rocks
yes so what's the what's the number one
tip don't look under rocks I have a
habit I've had this for a long time it's
probably a bad habit of if I see a stone
and I want to know what's underneath
I use my genitalia to flip it is that
something I shouldn't be doing here
lucky you yeah
yeah this is lucky me it is I don't even
have to move you get that rock over
there from right here
one penis joke okay next one is this
fellow here stinging ants very dangerous
which you're saying this air could kill
me yes absolutely you can come down with
full-blown anaphylactic shock in fact my
wife stood on the nest she turned white
the lips turned blue and she crapped the
pants and I had to take it off spittle
is your wife mind that you put in the
part when she craps your pants okay
we'll just leave that part out what is
that that's the trap despite all
sometimes you can get them to come out
if you just play around with the wig
that's good
taunting the deadly spider trying to get
it to come out of its hole is there any
chance I'm gonna get to use this I'm
sure we can follow something dude good
that let's see yours let's compare
[Applause]
trust me I got old in the states 20
years ago now how many of these do I
have to eat to sustain myself to stay
alive well probably 500 500 do you
thought this vest was a waste of time
look at that this is the pocket I used
to keep cocaine in now wombat berries
what a turn of events
hey this is abundant no wait these fall
out of trees yes
that's heavy it's why I'm looking up
we've got to be very careful under the
trees because some of these can weigh up
to ten kilograms so we could be killed
at any moment yes let's get out of here
there's a wind blowing I don't want to
be killed by a bunion nut remember I was
telling you about the tree funnel webs
now this one will kill you as well and
you're poking it why Oh hoping to get it
to come out so you can have a look at it
I'm good you can show me on the Internet
you set the reputation with all the
spiders you know you're like a Mormon at
the door ding-dong ding-dong you can
make a cup of tea out of that one a cup
of tea well great job Kevin we've been
out here for four hours wandering around
and so far we've got three wombat
berries and the makings of what looks to
be a third of a cup of tea this is what
they give you in coach now on most
airlines
hold it this branch is in my way
[Applause]
honey this is SWA likes Flocka philip
common name is sarsaparilla t you know
what it's starting to add up I now have
three berries and the makings of two
cups of different herbal teas basically
the diet of a 98 year old woman we've
collected a little bit of food now it's
time to make a fire yeah I smoked we can
throw it into that little birds nest
that little birds nest oh yeah
let me explain to everyone we shaved my
crotch about an hour
[Laughter]
we have fire this is amazing I can't
even primal that's a good feeling you
know let your first friction fire that
is my front well yes it is this is the
bunion nut buns all from the trees how
many nuts will fill you up
well the question whenever I hear the
cameraman James laughing I know someone
said something that could be construed
as dirty if you're a four-year-old
I even endless appetite for nuts are you
happy now Kevin I just like to lean my
head back and just drop those nuts in as
many as you can and I'm never satisfied
until I have hundreds of nuts in my
mouth big meaty nuts you liking this
yeah I bet you are doesn't matter to me
dip them in and dip them out nuts
this one looks done just before they
turn black right here that fleshy pop
any I'll go out and forage hey mate hey
look that I found kind of Jack Daniels
root yeah pulled it out of the ground
Bowl about the source from this out here
don't panic don't panic all right you
get lost
you don't panic just wander around until
you find little bottles of liquor nature
provides
[Applause]